(bright music)
- [Narrator] This ancient city was once
the cosmopolitan center
for the Kingdom of Pagan.
The first Kingdom to unify the
regions that created Burma.
The Bagan archeological zone
is an ancient city located
in Central Myanmar.
It is known for being covered
in incredibly ornate temples,
which stand out of the
sweeping green plains
and lush vegetation.
These temples were built
by the King's of Bagan
between 1057 and 1287.
There were originally around 10,000.
However, today, just over 2,000 remain
in varying states of repair.
The others have been lost
due to Mongol invasions
and, in more recent times, earthquakes.
The remaining temples are maintained
and are constantly undergoing restorations
to keep them intact for
future generations to enjoy.
(bright music)